I'm 0 sir the new lobby boy 0 you say
yes sir well I've never heard of you
never laid eyes on you who hired you mr.
Moser sir mr. Marsh up yes miss you
gusta am I to understand you've
surreptitiously hired this young man in
the position of a lobby boy he's been
engaged for a trial period pending your
approval of course yeah it's just josh i
love you but I absolutely forbid you to
go up against this professor in his own
classroom we have too much at stake the
whole thing's rigged to make you look
like an idiot if you weren't into law
school you can't afford to flunk this
class human a/c could be disastrous
real an arc to hold the innocent when
the Creator sense is still used to wipe
out the wicked from this world return to
your cities of Cain no we have all been
judged I have made up my back and you
stand alone and define me I'm not alone
I'm not sure how tough Captain America
is I mean the Hulk smash Thor has his
hammer
I'm telling you cap is one tough dude do
you think you can take Captain America
maybe hey uh we'll catch the next one